you hungry you ready it's time for some
more big game grub
this morning distilling revenue sharing
their queso dip recipe which is sure to
score a touchdown with your guests on
sunday
we are talking big game recipes i am in
the kitchen this is still in remedy they
have several locations across the valley
but this is the new one this is still
offering about chef jeff we are cooking
up some good stuff today absolutely
spicy
definitely well you know today i'm going
to be doing a brisket uh queso okay you
know with the super bowl coming up
there's going to be lots of brisket left
over hopefully with the tailgating
season the smart way to use that is uh
turn it into a queso turn it into a dip
you know add some cream cheese cheddar
cheese some charred corn uh some
jalapenos and take that chopped brisket
and just throw it in there cook it down
for about 20 minutes
and then take the rest of your brisket
get it nice and crispy kind of like
burnt ends finish it with some barbecue
sauce
and that's going to go right on the very
top kind of like a garnish you know
let's say you're you're not fancy and
you need to throw in some velveeta there
it's just gonna taste a little different
a little different yeah okay but hey if
that's what you want you're 100 i'm not
telling you what to do yeah absolutely
for me cheddar is better oh cheddar's
better i like that plant all right so
how do we serve it up so yeah so what
we're going to do is we've got our house
made kettle chips buy your favorite
flavor salt pepper uh you know whatever
whatever you you want to do or you can
buy them already pre-made with the
barbecue seasoning on them that's
totally okay as well
so once you get them in your bowl we're
just going to take our seasoning and
kind of toss it together now what's the
key to not burning this because i always
burn cheese all right you know with my
thing is if you're going to walk away
for even five minutes you want to go low
and slow this nice low low heat not even
medium just low and slow and keep
whisking it we're going to take some
green onions to finish
a little bit of tea hot cheese
boom and a char jalapeno
and that's it we try it yeah absolutely
[Music]
quick change
low and slow that's key with the cheese
so you can find this recipe and all of
the big game grub online 8newsnow.com
tomorrow we're going to head back to
soul belly for another really easy dish
that you can make for your super bowl
party